margot
bongo jerry il arrive dans un va
rencontrer deux mecs qui donne une voix
pure pour qui fit dame sa femme parce
que son père est super au groupe cari
ggp avec la bagnole et il faut du
silence la bla bla bla maker l'hyper
tout le temps et quand il enlève la
femme qui se posent dans la douche et
tombe dans l'escalier dans les pommes
pendant ce temps qui rival perd de sa
femme mais peuvent pas ne pas les payer
sa place de parking et du coup j'ai ri
et qu'il est temps la merde alors il
fait
sur ce voiture congelés plus des neiges
écoute il ya eu c'est lui c'est le dawa
parce que les mecs ils ont lu et sa
femme kate sauf que les mecs qui gère
trop mal mais ça part en couilles à
l'horizon un gros orage il me va ouvrir
la marche terry pour enquêter ils
peuvent baba elles deviennent direct ce
qui s'est passé est facile et envie de
vomir mais ça va mieux c'est chaud pour
jerry parce que papy légèrement touché
avec les mecs mais qu'elle n'a pas envie
alors il le perd son parti n'était
content canard surtout qu'un million de
là juste pour lui mais jugé n'est pas
d'accord alors il le passe au broyer
tient au moment où majar il avait 200
bourgueil déjà tsheri qui s'est enfui
par cette fois tu fais dans les gens
mais obama s'est pas tarie jerry et son
mari dessine un kabar pour atteindre
c'est trop bien